and released a backhand one timer on lucan's
mind he is so good at getting body position Bo
you a little fist pump there he's happy Yar
cro trying to get loose Do's on it they got
a penalty doy gets it off the board Sanderson
can't reach it there's a penalty coming up for
Sanderson now a two onone and how about this
a Sofer backhand pass that lands perfectly but
this is not an easy play for Robertson to be able
to knock this one up right over the leg and boom
and over the glove from Coral Robertson's got
the hands of the goal scorer and at the end he
just chops this one up and right underneath
the bar gie long shot gallager re gie takes
the shot and Gallagher's in front kicks it
knocks it down and then slides it around he
is so good at getting body position boy you
can see just in behind him doesn't have him
he's trying to front him doesn't knock it
down Gallagher does and then they reach and
I can't say Long Reach with Bron G with the
reach he's able to steer it in now he's got
a breakaway for the hat trick look David in and
he scores the hat trick for B davit he's gassed
here digging in deep just to get ahead of the
players and then what tremendous patience goes
forehand here all the way back to backand
in control of his body and puts the puck
Behind the goaline B you with a little fist pump
there he's [Music] happy Bard takes the puck SC
what a goal by Conor Bard how did he do that
what a steal bar down not even looking he makes
the goenda think that he's going to pass it and
just puts it in Beauty love the celebration at
the Panthers fans too kind of like what are you
looking at before puts the sword in and gives
it right back to him here's a chance for Skinner
now catching up to the puck on a breakway Skinner
D score just gner picks it up in motion and able
to get separation and when he does he just puts
a quick hold the move you see how he got back
on his heels and escape and changed Direction
real quick as soon as he started making the
move towards the net got right on the heels
right there and look at how quick those feet
were gold zero chance on that one picked up
by cadri cadry in with a power move to the slau
she scores cadri great move off the board did a
wonderful job of protecting the puck cadri or the
puck back to his forehand that is so hard to do
spinning and then just elevates over the right pad
fortunately for cadri is able to whip that one by
monmo one timer over the head of hook is put in
and D Mar with some absolute sorcery from the
corner when you least expect it the bank in from
the bat angle off the helmet on a one-time on the
backand Sega Genesis play almost just held down
the shoot button and released a backhand one timer
off the end boards off lucan's mind pass ahead and
on the left side with speed it's Kyle Conor off
the wing Conor right out front SC there's number
55 that breaks the play watch where he takes this
pass it's off his skate onto his stick all in
one motion then that number 81 go to work and
do the rest forehand backand and the puck and
all the Defenders for Nashville end up in the
back of the net what a sizzling play from shely
into the hands of Conor just like the Predators
do with smashville for bu in drags and holds he
shoots go oh what a great individual effort there
by Philip forsberg to create that scoring chance
but you said it Willie credit O'Reilly here with
going to the net hard causing a distraction
watch this tow drag watch how far it brings
his pu back slides right to the middle forsberg
just puts her five hole what a beauty finding
it his tiffet moves around the trono in on go he
scor oh and temp dazzles on his way in and what a
move on patrono he puts it behind him he's on the
off Wing So when he takes it to his forehand he's
got a lot of net to work with boy what a play
and what a finish by tip it and Alexi protus to
win a battle bring it ahead short hand to mcel he
score protus did a great job of pushing that puck
to mcel but oh my holy jumping what a nice play
by McMichael forehand backand up over top of the
Fallen golender who ended up doing a snow angel
and didn't have much space to cover the top half
of the net fourth overtime game for the capitals
it's the third and here's a chance for barov right
in and he scores it's Reinhardt the winner just
15 seconds into overtime this game is over with a
long stretch pass and an incredible play Reinhardt
uses a strong part of his body protects the pl to
look like he was going to the backand and instead
he brings it to the forehand and then he's able
to hoist it just an outstanding play by Reinhardt
after a great pass by barov back into the hands
of Cole stolen by B sett for scor what a move by
GRE B and that beauty of a goal as descends on the
board luk chip play by Cole loses the punt Bon
sticks with it and this is just hands in tight
takes it from orand to backand back to forehand
and elevates it as he gets the Smith to bite on it
hands it off to Crosby looking in front they score
the magic once again Crosby gel back of the net of
Beauty and the touch of this pass Josh the timing
to put it on gensel Stick driving to the back door
what a play Malin rumbles in nice drop pass Russ
will try again comes behind the N raer Go are
you kidding me take that one to the B Brian Russ
Twitches a California sweep and the Penguins top
the Kings 43 and OT Brian Russ would not be denied
and how about that you get your heart ripped out
a little bit with a game you think is over and
Brian rusters goes right back and says you know
what I like this kind of a goal better this is a
little fancier Matthews throws on the head knocked
down loose pucko a KN rning and score highlight
real stuff from William El that acceleration out
of a pile and then the strength he shrugs off
Anderson Anderson puts a stick on him doesn't
impact them all pulls it around badar and Tucks it
home beautiful goal fin waiting for around the KNE
Lander C what a pass to scores oh my goodness what
a pass he tied himself into a pretzel got hammered
and then put it right on a platter for John tarz
that's nice you know John tarz has made a career
out of being incredible right there rebound there
now sanheim in sanheim Cuts in the back he's gone
little Bobby or in him there I mean you got
to have guts to take it to the net but you
also have to have the skill but he gets the puck
around the Stick of the Pope Che of doal and then
on his backand able to bring it home Michael able
to flip the check up Addison has Carlson in front
score what a set up William Carlson short headed
from Jack EO look at eiko come from underneath
just so powerful Addison tries to hit him but he's
so strong how about the pass patience Carlson just
drifts back and he's going to lift this perfect
pass right to Carlson who elevates that puck puts
a glove side upstairs taken here by Raymond St
score beautiful play everybody thinks he's going
all the way around including Martin he stops
up but he creeps back in front and tucked it
in he made it look awfully Easy by the time Martin
realized what he was doing he'd already drawn his
right leg away from the goal post and that was
the end of it right there as it's play it along
and carcone has it four unbelievable shot that is
the hockey fan in me right there what an absolute
rocket that is Conor Bard like he's going to pull
this in and boom he lets it go go uses Yosi as a
screen and throws this far side poed in that's a
goal scorer's goal and SOS can believe what just
happened and now sod raises in to the net now
back in front they score what an effort there
by Brandon sad he gets a little fake on one
of the best if not the best defenseman in the
league kale Mar and then once he gets wide he's
got such good speed and he's got good strength
on the puck drops his shoulder leans in and then
that's the presence of mind to find bra save from
flber what a beautiful stretch here's mcav off
the trickles home they're back the dynamic duo
right there this is a perfect pass by Leon dry
watch this he knows McDavid yell he wanted it
right to the farm blue line and he shoots this
pu gets a little bit of a b they're not getting
a lot of Puck luck they've created their Puck
luck in this one new Shane Springs it San has a
step Zan score oh he is him what a beautiful pass
right through the guts of the ice Sean took off
as soon as duchan had partial possession to that
puck Tyler hit the gas got it at the Blue Line
undressed the mot more moves than a snake falling
out of a tree and then tosses a backand over top
pck scores cross ice pass from zaka through the
middle of the ice bump it wide zaka with a nice
little pull up and the timing by Pono was perfect
he come down the off Wi he positions himself for
the one timer possibility zaka delivers it he gets
down into that one knee one timer just rips it for
Lev like can get a cross I don't care if he got a
cross I'm not sure he would have got it anywhere
that was a bull here's Carlson a shot to blocked
it in the PED goal Sydney Crosby goes upstairs
what a pass by Carlson and there's that I call
it a chop tip and how good is he at those tips
it's out of this world he shows Carlson he goes
hey hey I'm right here back door what a oh what a
[Music]
[Music] moment